hey everyone dfolo here and in today's
video we're going over one of the most
Reckless and absolutely hyped moments so
far from throughout the freaking goated
story that is Jujutsu Kaizen I
absolutely love this fight like I knew
how to talk about this solely at some
point the new characters that are
revealed and then literally killed
straight away and of course the
destruction that our girl Marquis didn't
commit upon the holes in Clan it's just
pure Insanity like I don't even really
need to say but I think it's plainly
obvious to me that people like big Giga
and Fujimoto are out here changing the
entire perception of what a goaded
female Shonen character can actually do
instead of like an almost dead sea
Sakura type character with these
freaking ballsy chicks who love fighting
and throwing hands just as much as the
dudes around them with some of these
chicks like Maki Yuki and even makima
from chainsaw man surpassing almost
every other dude around them and
becoming an utterly terrifying force
that hardly anyone could ever take down
of course if you do enjoy content just
like this Rogue over a bunch of
different fights entire arcs or come
complete stories from a multitude of
different series then make sure you hit
that subscribe button and also be sure
to leave a like on the video as it
really helps out with pushing my content
to a bunch of new amazing people anyway
so firstly I guess a little bit of
context is vital in explaining the
origin of this entire conflict here
pretty much straight after Yuji Megami
and choso finished the conversation they
were having together about the current
state of things they head over to the
number one thumb himself master tingen
who explains to everyone the rundown of
this so-called culling game after this
extremely long explanation which barely
even touches the surface of what's
currently going on everyone ends up
sitting out on their own different paths
one of these individual paths just
happens to be this journey of absolute
pain and Carnage that our girl Maki
decides to take anyway enough of that so
back and enjoy yourselves as we finally
dive into the demise of the zinning clan
I kind of like how that rhymed there so
in order to fulfill her role in helping
with the culling game Marky returns to a
place which is never fell felt welcome
as she enters these Indian household to
collect the curse tools she is
immediately greeted by the misogynistic
neo-year seeing how scarred she is now
he taunts her as he believes almaki head
was your attractive nurse and now that
it's gone he asks if he should
mercilessly bully her like he used to in
the past he continues to throw abuse
towards our girl however she just
ignores his crude ass and heads on
underground after deceiving some of the
stairs into the underground Corridor
Maki finds her mother awaiting her there
she reminds her daughter that they
cannot enter the warehouse to watch Maki
like the boss she has nonchalantly holds
up their keys while saying that Mega me
is the new head of the clan and gave her
the motion and a flashback we find out
that Maki was actually the person who
revealed to migami that he had become
the head of the clan heavily reluctant
with the idea of being head making me
suggest that he let Marty take over for
him instead but she denies the option as
she knows no one would accept her she
points out that he is inherited these
eating Clans prized tin Shadows
technique and achieved its domain
expansion Mega me really didn't want to
take the role as head and asked if
things like acceptance mattered if she
becomes a clan hid she would still get
the resources but Maki doesn't believe
she's good enough to make this home a
place where my belongs not yet once Maki
said that about her sister migami
finally understood in the present as
Marquis cruises past her mother she
suddenly screamed at by her to stop and
instead come back maki's mother asks why
her daughter is always like this and
tells her to at least make her mother
proud once for giving birth to her
however Maki just completely ignores her
pleas and continues on until she finds a
door that seals the cursed Warehouse
after using the key to unseal the chains
holding their doors together Maggie
finally enters however she's instantly
shocked to see her father unexpectedly
sitting inside of the room without a
single curse tool in sight maki's father
who was another of the misogynist
reveals that he anticipated marky's move
and emptied out all of the curse tools
beforehand he stands up and reveals mice
injured body behind him Mai seen Mikey
there for the first time calls her an
idiot for coming which is really random
when you put it in that context
meanwhile janichi meets with naoya to
fill him in on the circumstances it's
explained there through them that it's
been deemed a crime to unseal subtle
Gojo so this inning Clan is going to
execute migami Maki and Mai as Rebels
plotting to do so now he is amused by
the plan while killing his own daughters
will boost ogi's credibility know your
wonders if he is actually okay with the
idea to which as the battle begins
between father and daughter junichi
reveals to naoya that this plan was
originally ogi's idea which just goes to
show like how up the city Clan is
and how old all of their thoughts are
like look at the house the woman the men
the clothes like literally everything
it's it's time to move forward Zen and
Clan you just you guys just do not get
it like don't get me wrong I actually
love it because that's the whole point
of the seeking away to make you hate the
group while still wanting to know more
about all of them especially naoya like
that dude has just reading absolutely
perfectly back as the battle starts off
Ogie activates his falling Blossom
emotion he explains that he kept my
alive as a bargaining chip in case Marky
arrived with any unknown curse tools
that caused in an emergency situation
Marky wields juuzo's Masterpiece the
goated curse tool dragon bone its effect
or ability I guess is that after
accumulating cursed energy the user can
inject it out the back of the blade to
increase its cutting power Mikey plans
to take advantage of ogi's ignorance and
bait entering a single strike Jewel
while actually intending to hit back
multiple times just before Indian's
standoff Augie asks why Mikey thinks
neobito was chosen over him as head of
the clan Mahi asks if it's because he's
a terrible person willing to kill his
own children which instantly prompts
Okie to start the fire light as Ogie
darts forward she blocks his first slash
and follows up with an attack of her own
utilizing the momentum granted by cursed
energy shooting out the back of the
blade Obi tries to Parry but quickly
notices his katana blade is actually
broken allowing Marky to get behind him
and go for the finishing blow however
with some unrealistically fast timing
from an old timer Okie quickly spins
around and counters for this blazing
curse technique momentarily solidifying
his blade before he cuts Maki down
Mikey's already busted eye as a gain
hurts and cuts open along with her lower
abdomen which was sliced through from
the attack left with deathly injuries
Maki doesn't understand what happened
until she realizes that Oogie's blade
has been replaced by the Flames of his
cursed energy as she falls to fated
okishides a tear and reveals he couldn't
become head of the clan because his
children are indeed worthless
man I like I said I hate this in
family's ideology and like Jiu Jitsu in
general like if you wanted your kids to
improve you would teach them techniques
and not treat them like absolute ass all
the time that's not Marky who's the
failure on this like situation Mr ogisan
it was your failure as a hero to teach
your children correctly and guide them
and now it is time to pay the
consequences as Ogie drags his twin
daughter's bleeding bodies down a
corridor leaving a trail of their blood
behind him he explains why Marquee lost
he says that she stepped in close and
treated her opponent like a swordsman
and not a sorcerer he repeats that he
did not become head of the clan because
of the quality of his children
naobito's projection sorcery technique
doesn't have much of a history outside
of passing it down to na oh yeah so this
was not a determining factor and a
choice the only difference between them
was how strong their children turned out
to be Oggy states that children must not
hold back their parents and tosses his
daughter down a flight of stairs like
the trash he thinks they are into an
empty large room he explains this area
is for training and discipline a
plethora of course Spirits are kept fear
they will eat the twins as soon as Obi
leaves he mocks Marky and claims her
Heavenly restriction is nothing compared
to other sorcerers who trained and
reinforced their muscles with curse
energy every single day for years on end
her father then turns his back on his
daughters and says farewell to the
stains of his life one final time before
the curses move in Mai is able to sit up
and puts marky's head on her lap as she
feels Mark is heart beating she knows
how tough her twin truly is okay I used
to hate Mai but like really in this
moment right here it fully changed my
total outlook on her I always thought
that she was just another of the Zenon
household content with the way things
are and that's why she was always a
towards Marquee but right now we
find out that Mai suspected that this
would happen someday and is ready to do
what is necessary to save her sister she
opens marky's mouth and says this sucks
before breathing the life back into her
suddenly Marky awakens somewhere on a
beach as if she's been rescued from
drowning and she's like so cute
literally like she breathed the ear back
into her after drowning in the crap from
her family like it's such a great
analogy right here from Giga she's
laying next to Mai who explains that
she's going to use a construction
technique to make something but will
then die from this strange due to the
injury she's already sustained Mike gets
up in his sand and walks into the water
or saying goodbye and wishing her twin
good luck in life this greatly confuses
Marquee who gets up and beats her sister
to come back Mai explains that she knew
for a while that twins are a bad Omen
for Sorcerers to gain one must give
however that rule doesn't always apply
to twins because curse energy treats
them as One Singular entity even if
Marky wants to get stronger she can't
because my doesn't so was sad and as
messed up as it is as long as Maya's
around Marky can never fully develop in
an attempt to get her sister to stop
Maki tells her that she understands but
she still doesn't want to lose her
sister and runs after her asking for her
to come home again Mike stands her hand
to Marky telling her that she is only
going to leave her one thing so make
sure to throw the wrist away my will
take away all of the acoustic energy
when she dies so in return she asks Mahi
to promise her just one thing destroy
everything Maggie takes a small read
from his sister's hand and reflects on
the time they were happy as children and
the next moment hell itself has returned
as Marty awakens in reality noticing
that she's holding a sword handle
instead of a read and a moment of beauty
she's been protected by her sister who
has tragically toppled over her with no
more Life Lift a newborn body
overwhelmed by emotion Mahi cries out
and tells Mai to wake up while a bunch
of cursed Spirits Rush up behind her
skipping over to the old man as he walks
away he notices something that just
doesn't feel right and turns around to
see what's up Suddenly all of the cursed
Spirits are exercised instantaneously
confusing Okie as their presences just
vanish for him okay like remember our
girl is now outputting zero NADA none
literally no curse energy at all in her
staff it's just them pure gains time to
see what really pays off physical
strength through training your entire
life or curse strength ogi oh he readies
his Katana and says Maki strolling
through the Shadows of the doorway
before she gently places Mai's body down
okie's body begins to trample with fear
as he knows his mind has tried its best
to forget this feeling Mucky emerges
from these shadows and instantly reminds
him of no one other than a demon Warrior
who possessed no cursed energy the
breaker of Fate himself toji Zenon
struck with a jolt of fear Oogie
immediately activates his curse
technique blazing courage causing his
katana's Broken Blade and scorching
Flames that blaze a circle around him
with his scorching blade pointed at
Marky Oogie threatens to burn his
worthless child to the Bone and a fight
to the death however before he could
even finish talking Marty like The
Frigid Beast she's always been
effortlessly decapitates his head while
walking past him in fact I don't even
know how much of a specific buff this
was like we have to get big old broken
Ronin on it or something but this slash
was so damn fast that Okie never even
saw it coming Maki stops behind her
father's defeated corpse as it falls to
the ground she looks at the last gift
Mai gave her then ready to keep her
promise gripsley cursed tall in her hand
and tells Mai it's time to get started
time to start the absolute destruction
that is about to happen like oh I can't
wait ding ding ding ding ding ding
literally like as an alarm bell sounds
out notifying the zidane Clan janichi
and naoya leave their mating room and go
into a hallway young Ranter zinin finds
them and tells jinichi that Maki has
gone mad and actually killed Okie which
leaves the others completely surprised
so since these inning Clan is like just
freaking massive they have a variety of
different groups consisting of people
with varying skill levels one of these
is the 50-man kukuru unit that gets
dispatched to apprehend Marquee
following in the ass way of every
scene in male this Captain noblewaji
Zenon tells his men that she must have
killed Ogie in his sleep or in the
bathroom obviously it's severely
underestimating her stream this kukuru
unit is made up of Zen men who do not
manifest and innate technique but are
still able to use cursed energy they end
up fighting Maki in the curse Spirit
Room and Surround her with at least 20
men from the unit standing there alone
looking like the complete hellhound
where the dragon bone in one hand and
Mai's Creation in the other Maki can
only think about her sister she wonders
what her plan was and if she should
really have given up on becoming a
sorcerer alongside my she figures that
that might have been the right answer
all along and apologizes to her sister
for potting her through all of the pain
that she did from around her the 20
kukuru unit Fighters all attack while
Mahi remembers Mai's final request
destroy everything Maki opens her eyes
just as one of the men attempts to slash
her instantly and on some freaking
Matrix level she avoids the blade
and cuts off both of the man's hands in
one fluid motion then vaults over his
back and cuts down several of his allies
before finally be hitting the fodder
fall below her despite their numbers the
kukuru Guna is frankly nothing compared
to the now unrestricted Marty who
effortlessly kills one after another and
successively brutal fashion oh my Lord I
love this fight like the look on
everyone's freaking face as she's just
annihilating them as perfect this
absolute egg no Milwaukee arrives back
somehow expecting Marquee to actually
have been finished off already yet ezzy
strollsen he's unpleasantly surprised to
see that all of his men have been turned
into bloody corpses by an unscathed
Marquee suddenly our new beloved icon of
female strength now this is a surge of
cursed energy nearby coming from chojiro
zinen instantly she's tossed flying up
into the ear by a pair of gigantic stone
hands the then attempt to smash her
while she's falling back down to earth
nobody recognizes this attack as
chojiro's curse technique and notes the
Decay have now arrived which by the way
is a group made up of only the strongest
comprised of everyone in the family with
a semi-grade one or higher rankine so
now the proper fight Begins the stone
hands aren't enough to hold Mahi as she
tears her way back out novawaki and
chojiro attempt to stop her but she jams
her hands into their throats at blinding
speed literally killing them both before
they could even react ranta watching
this uses his paralyzing technique to
try and hold Maki in place while yelling
to hurry up and finish her off while do
you think she Sprints in to kill her
Mackie fights back and forcibly breaks
out of ranta's technique this literally
sends his technique back at him or
something similar to that inflicting a
horrendous amount of damage to his face
still despite bleeding profusely Ryan to
make sure to tell junichi that Maki has
indeed become just like tojin however
unlike toji who never decided to destroy
the entire clan on a whim Mahi will do
that if she is not killed here and now
junichi attacks Marky and launches a
huge number of cursed energy propelled
fists running down from the sky at her
this problems everything in the
immediate area which causes ranta to
believe they actually succeeded at his
final moments rancidin collapses on his
knees while they smile thinking they won
and succumbs to the previous strain of
his injuries while Mahi the complete and
utter God walks out of the dust and
smoke for janichi's head hanging from
her first
finally the misogynistic neoyazinen who
secondly under being an absolute hoe as
the head of the hay Squad confronts
Marky via a small traditional
japanese-style bridge that extends over
a nice Pond standing there he of all
people calls Mahi crawl and asks if she
even has a human heart to which Mahi
were they cold and callous face replies
no as your heart has already been taken
from her skipping until we flash back
during naoya's childhood we find that
he's always been wrapped in Cotton wool
and constantly praised by his family
members he was recognized as a genius
and many always believed he would grow
into the head of the clan after naobito
love how Megami just showed up on the
block out of nowhere and messed up that
entire plan for him anyways anyways Neil
you heard of a black sheep and a clan
who didn't have any cursed energy and
went to see how pitiful that person was
however after seeing him naoya was
physically shaken upon seeing toji's
Cold Yet unconsumed eyes back in reality
now nalia initiates the fight quickly
sending a series of Rapid punches
towards her however Maki is able to
Parry the majority of them or try and
account the number of movements in that
singular moment sadly while she's big
brain in his technique now he interrupts
it and grabs her causing her to be
Frozen inside a frame then using the
Extreme Velocity his technique provides
naioya kicks Maki through civil stone
structures surrounding the area now
you're standing there thinking he is the
pop G as adamant to himself that Marquis
is not toji regardless of a new Boost in
power yes she ain't even at the same
power level yet bro she just unlocked
the full extent of her Heavenly
restriction like Goku wasn't all of a
sudden Super Saiyan 3 when he unlocked
Super Saiyan 1 like it's not how it
works you've got you've still got to
train and build time you know anyways
now you thinks that the sin of
insignificant people is the ignorance of
strength everyone misjudged toji because
of his lack of cursed energy and naillou
doesn't believe anyone other than Gojo
truly understood who he actually was
using his curse technique now he
continually builds up momentum and
overwhelms Marky with one high speed
move after another being a massive toji
in goju Fanboy now he desires to prove
that he is the only one who will stand
with him as one of the strongest not
Marquee even with her improved abilities
Maki is starting to get hurt by narious
attacks and struggles to keep up
admitting that this situation is getting
bad for neoya and like in his fight with
choso he won't stop building up speed
this time he understands that strength
equals weight and speed and plans to
pierce Marty at Max velocity having
already gone supersonic Mikey gained a
steel body that is broken away from
cursed energy in exchange for Maya's
life she welcomes a head-on collision
and takes the stance of the shiranui
Garter which for all of my Japanese
lovers out there is a specific form that
sumo wrestlers take Maki attempts to
take on the brunt of Naomi's supersonic
speed in order to stop his movements
even if it means sacrificing few rubs
appearing to stay through maki's
defensive strategy now he attacks her
with his palm and doing so it forces
Maki to follow the 24 frames per second
roll of projection sorcery failure to do
so means being frozen inside a frame for
one second like what just happened with
her previously when she was kicked
across the yard still moving at top
speed and seen as adversary as nothing
more than an imposter now who believes
Maki is frozen and prepares to finish
her off however Maki actually isn't even
phased by his technique and is even
obeying this specific 24-frame rule of
it now being able to move fast enough
Maki turns around and counter attacks
intercepting the area's path with her
first now your attempts to call Maki a
fake but before he finishes she smashes
his face into the ground with a
monstrous punch that ends the fight and
he forms now your skull now acting like
the absolute boss she is she looks down
on her pathetic bloody cousin and asks
him to repeat that
so I guess all of the action in regards
to this eating Clan mutilation ends
there but we still have just one more
massive moment I probably should Chuck
in here for all of you guys because I oh
my Lord it wraps everything up just
perfectly having Lefty Battlefield now
Marky finds her mother in a kitchen area
like of course like where else would she
be and he's dead in the household it's
just so so freaking sexist off them
marky's mother tells you to stay back
but Maki wants to know why she screamed
at her to come back earlier in the
corridor to destroy to even recall what
happened only moments prior mucky's
mother can only ask what Maki is talking
about they're satisfied Maki approaches
her mother who yells out in panic
several times before a blood is
splattered on the wall okay I'm not
gonna lie this does confuse me a slight
bird I think Mumsy turned the blade on
herself right here but honestly let me
know what you guys think down below I I
really don't think Marky actually sliced
up her mum outside throughout and around
the estate the hay and the kokoru squads
have been completely decimated with
their corpses lining the area somehow
like the cockroach she is nailya heavily
injured but still somehow barely alive
walks around pouring blood from his face
until he finally collapses through a
door onto the ground inside he mocks
Marky for not ending him and leaving him
like this when out of freaking nowhere
marky's mother walks up behind him with
her throat already slit and bleeding so
she's definitely approaching death for
sure but still somehow holding a kitchen
knife difficult Zen In A state-like
Thing naioya who's currently too pitiful
to even protect himself then is probably
the woman he hated the most the mother
of Marky and Mai stab him through the
back while they goddamn kitchen knife
which by the way is something that this
said should happen to any
female who is weaker than any man so
like oh my God you've got to chill out
with him sneaky little like four Shadow
ones here and there now it calls her a
piece of trash but either way ends up
dying a pitiful death with a woman
laying on top of him unable to do
anything about it on top and fading away
the girl's mother admits that she really
was was glad to have given birth to two
amazing girls what a freaking battle
well not really about it was more of an
obliteration of like a neurodivergent
group of people but still it was
purifier scene Marky pop off like this
and Merc her entire Clan I don't know
all of the zenings but I think it's only
Mega me and Marky now that are like
considered a part of that Clan also I
just love how like this non-ditzy or
childlike female lead character Buzz jjk
has going on at the moment like we've
got the big teddy goth waifu with meimei
salary woman me were what kind of chicks
you into Yuki Novara the carpenter Momo
the like wizard witch or whatever shoko
the doctor Marky is like literally the
re-embodiment of toji and Mai literally
had a construction ability construction
it's crazy I don't know all of them are
just like brilliant female characters
that just seem to have what feels like a
personality to them more than other
shows and this doesn't just apply to the
female characters and she's usually cars
and of course it's literally anyone and
it's what makes the story the world
pretty much anything to do with it so
damn enjoyable so that officially brings
us to the very end of what is marky's
Massacre of her entire family obviously
if you guys have enjoyed this video and
want to see more stuff just like it in
the future then make sure you hit the
Subscribe button down below and also be
sure to leave a like on it as it really
helps with pushing my stuff to a bunch
of new amazing people of course this is
actually only a section of what is the
laser perfect preparation Arc that I'm
going to be like uploading in around
seven days from now so you guys can look
forward to that if you guys are like
expecting a Big Arc video to come out
this week I'm just not finished it yet
it's almost done but we'll be there soon
enough I'm going to be also releasing
like more fight videos from throughout
the past and like my Shibuya incident
and maybe even in my Demon Slayer videos
to try and garden new people towards the
channel that aren't interested in the
like super long videos but I'm more
interested in say these shorter fighting
videos that I upload and all that kind
of chairs obviously if you guys want to
even support me even further then just
you know like subscribing and watching
my videos which is absolutely enough
then there is my patreon which I will
leave in the description down below but
obviously you guys don't have to do that
but you know feel free to message me and
all that kind of jazz if you do end up
subscribing or following me over there
and I will 100 reply to you guys and all
of that you know stuff that you're meant
to do I don't know why people can't it's
not it's not that hard at the end of the
day and you know thank you to all my
patreons who have been subscribed for
the past you know like almost half a
year now shout out to all of you guys
you're freaking amazing but anyway for
now it's been your professional
degenerate develo and I'll see you all
in a burp bye